Ian Coby asks alien movies Ripley opens
up an airlock in space on two separate
occasions wouldn't opening the airlock
killed her pretty quickly yeah so what
you mean is you're in a vacuum and know
won't you just hold your breath and
you're not there long and I won't
explode or freeze or any gum it's some
tension on your skin because there is
pressure inside of you air will come out
of your lungs moving as the pressure
balance wants to equalize so your cheeks
will puff out and you've got to let some
air out but if you're just trying to
open an airlock and spend a little bit
of time in David get your suit to put on
your boots to close a norther door
plenty of time to do that oh really oh
yeah how lovely five ten minutes or like
thirty five minutes I know cuz you can't
hold your breath for ten minutes
even regularly I mean I would die yeah
as long as you can hold your breath you
okay to go oh and yeah so it's been
overheard played okay yeah whether you
explode inside right go okay David
Pellom desks physics limitations in the
Iron Man movies is there theoretical
power supply that would be small enough
to carry and still provide adequate
power up to the outlet ah certainly that
matter antimatter drive in his chest
would do almost essentially everything
he was yeah except what would the
antimatter touch to contain it in his
chest that's the big problem okay
Alexandre LaChapelle asks will the
artificial intelligence we create ever
reach the same level we see in sci-fi I
don't see why not
look already our artificial intelligence
beats us in chess yeah run Saturday in
nuts in jeopardy so sure sure it doesn't
sound dangerous to me the tricky part is
will it one day ever become diabolical
or enslave us or useless as food exactly
and the answer is maybe but probably not
I'm skeptical yeah pain injuries tasks
or jutsu risa hate injuries that's good
robots really be programmed to follow
Asimov's law of robotics and if they
could do you predict life like
artificial intelligence in the near
future we can program computers to do
anything we want even speak Spanish
period period and so this whole thing
about height amounts three rules and one
of the guys that Rob I cannot kill
the creator of the robot yeah and so the
point is you can program to do anything
Lego so name one robot we have the kills
people in all of the drones
yes exactly the robot doesn't have to
look like people it disaster response is
that's the kill just you know planes
today are robots yeah you're they're
monorail in airports or robots there's
nobody driving the damn thing
not even a bunch of kids not nobody
so so yeah yeah I don't see why yes they
do anything we want and here's the thing
whether they take women a achieve
consciousness on their own I don't know
how that can happen unless we program
them to achieve consciousness on their
own just to perform tasks okay I think
well we should let computers do okay
come on okay Larissa J Levy asks is
there any possible way to make a radio
out of coconuts but great question you
have you gotta love the professor yeah
Gilligan's I know switch into few
questions from Twitter yeah you need
some metal to make or you need some
conductors you need something to conduct
in coconuts barely condemned no but you
can make a one of the alarm clock out of
a potato power it yes power it but their
wires sticking into it you need metal
right conductors for that okay
so Rachel fender asks in line with
future amaz predictions of the future is
alcohol of viable substance for a robot
fuel hi mmm Brazil yes has most of no
the third largest aerospace industry in
the world it's a twenty billion dollar
industry at a point is 18,000 people and
they invented an airplane that runs on
alcohol unleash on yak or pure alcohol
so here we are drinking alcohol on
airplane our airplanes and they're
making airplanes that can run on alcohol
which is essentially solar-powered
because alcohol is derived from plant
products playing products get their
energy from the Sun nice ok Wally after
700 years in space humans lost bone mass
when did wall-e sorriest for Wally no
you're right
sorry been a person in the movie wall-e
thank you
after 700 years in space humans lost
bone mass and gain fat with their bodies
really work back under no no no if you
look our bodies don't work on earth when
will you do is sit and watch TV right
let alone
yeah beyond space yeah you go in space
and then you gain to get fatter if you
don't exercise so if we sent enemies to
outer space and brought them back in
like 20 years we could beat the crap
crap what you do is you spin off the
space station you spin off the scraps so
that you have artificial gravity right
it solves the problem entirely if we had
them in super gravity rooms we could
make them very powerful even stronger
caress that's you know different from
just increasing the weight on within the
gym no different next it sounds more fun
we're running quick okay that's what
Jeff de l'aube asks in dune energy
shields allow slow-moving objects to
pass through but prevent fast-moving
objects is this possible I I've never
figured that one out so I'm not because
it's made up thanks that's fine let me
not say that it's not possible unlikely
there are things that you can move
slower through faster than trying to
move fast through that's true yeah like
really viscous liquids yes if you try to
go fast through the there's a partial
vacuum that picks up behind you and
slows you down yeah it's like the muck
of mud and but move slowly
we gotta go ah Eugene thanks for coming
thank you so much guys owe me cosmic
queries sci-fi